i'm jen chin fun the
i think 34 or 35th uh student of peter
bigel uh the main reason is ambiguity
because momoshu graduated the same year
he's a bit older so therefore he may be
34 i'm 35.
okay and so it's my uh peter the uh
intellectual house has uh inspired and
guide many of our research
and his kind and
caring gentlemen that touch many spend
our lives so it's my great pleasure and
i let me thank to
harry
in advance for i mean his understood on
peter's influence on his career and
therefore by similarity his influence on
all of our career here so harry
is the floor is yours
thank you
thank you for your introduction
first i apologize for not being able to
make it uh all that i wish i could be
there and uh from this vlog i saw that
it's a lot of fun
and it's
truly uh truly a great honor
to give this talk i'm grateful uh of
this opportunity to talk about peter's
influence on my career
and peter is not my advisor
but i hope and from this talk you will
see that
these variations i received from peter
could be more than what anyone would
wish for from an advisor
i'll focus on
three
topics
a large occurrence matrix mean
statistical network analysis
and variation of influence or more
broadly
strategical and computational guarantee
of non-commerce organization province
in 2007
i give a talk at berkeley thanks to bin
and peter took him out after lunch at
the factory club
i remember i had a stop the problem then
i couldn't finish the food
but
that was the best lunch ever
and peter was so enthusiastically
and talking about and his work on
logical writing matrix estimation it was
so inspiring
so okay
that was a journal with lisa
thank you visa for organizing these
uh peter analisa
a story a covariance matrix estimation
and a p by v matrix
so there are an order of a piece of
braille unknown primers
it would be very unnatural to assume we
would need a sample size at least an
order of polynomial p
to get a consistent estimation
but once they proved
that was amazing
for a class of coins and matrices
the summer size you need
is just more logic
that sounds you know too good for you
so let's review the uh uh the paper a
little bit
so we observe x one to x and id
with a covariance matrix sigma p by p
without loss of generality
we assume the means equal to zero
so the goal is to estimate the current
matrix
under this vector norm
in spawn of a time series theta
let's assume that
and sigma iga
decay to zero
when sigma ij moves away from the
diagonal
and decays to zero with the polynomial
rate
from that assumption
immediately
we have this very simple fact
if we look at sigma iga
and far away from the diagonal
and this k position positions away
from the diagonal okay if you're
plugging k over here then you get k plus
1 to the power minus alpha plus one
then
we look at the row sum
of those
inches absolute uh a value of those
entries
then we get such a level bound and the
upper bound is k to the power of minus
alpha times a constant
so this is a very simple fact but it's a
very important fact we are going to use
it at least twice in this talk
so let's start with the sample
covariance
sigma iga actually is a very good
estimator of unknown sigma assimilation
tilde is actually is a very good
isolator of sigma iga
first is unbiased
second the standard deviation is one
over squared
so let's start from the sample coverage
and then
consider a bunion estimator
as you may see my iga maximization from
the sum of coverage
if sigma ij is close to the diagonal
if it's far away from the diagonal then
is made by
zero so that is clearly inspired
by this time series uh assumption
and this is a beautiful analysis
usually it could be challenging to
control
the spectrum
so they control the spectrum but the
matrix are unknown
which is the maximum
raw sum for a symmetric
or column sum because a is symmetric
like equivalent
so let's do a
decomposition
of the risk
by triangular inequality
this advance this bias square
the pi square we have this upper bound
due to
this simple fact
and
sum of covalence is another biased
estimator
and for the variance support
every row has a number of k
non-zero inches
uh do you have questions and i should
answer questions
oh okay uh
i do not see any cuts in there
for every energy
is an order of
square root of p of n times maybe a big
constant
so the matrix l one ohm
will be bounded above by k times square
root of rho b of n
if you're squared then you get k square
times log b of n
and trade off of these two terms
by sending k equal to this
then we get a fascinating rate
as long as log p is equal to later on
it's consistent
under the matrix are one one
and consequently
under the spectrum
we followed this work
very closely
but what we did it was very minor
we tried to deal with
spectrum directly
actually what we did
was
to consider the variance part on the
spectrum directly
for the bias part we use the same
alphabet
this is a binding matrix
it can similar read as a lot of k by k
matrix
stacking
stacking together
for one two vector matrix
we expect
expected upper bound square root of
kelvin
if you're squared then you get k of n
but there are a lot of p of those
matrices
and and the tailbone people had already
proved to tell the tail probability is
sub gaussian
and then we have another bond low p of n
as well
a trade off between the first term and
this photon
and gives
a rate of estimation under the spectrum
node
we also show that
and q of n is also for the right choice
of k is also
a lower bound
and log of p of n lower bound can be
established by the comps method and the
k of n lower bound can be established by
ashwagandha
so in summary a brief summary and what
we did was very
minor and what we shared was just
that and uh
depending procedure or a variant of
bunion procedure and proposed
by peter analisa
was optimal
and if we choose the k
properly
in the same year
they had another paper in the unknowns
of statistics
consider sparse a covariance matrix
estimation
i believe that was the last issue of the
honors of that year 2008
and one of the primary spaces they
consider
is
is
every row and every column is sports
there will be no more than s and nine
zero entries for each row and column
then consider and hard threshold
and possibly with a relatively large c
over there
and if c is large enough
and from
the classical
a result of
uh downhill johnson and hearthstone
we know that
and every row and every column of sigma
hat minus sigma
is still and as sparse
with high probability
then the matrix l random can be well
controlled it's just as times the
maximum value of each energy which can
be well controlled by square root log p
of n times the constant
so
then we get a lava bound to estimate a
sigma
under the spectral node uh for the
sparse covalent matrix simulation
we have already seen that
measures l one ohm
could be very bad bound
to bound the spectral node
so then the question is is this rate
optimal
so and uh we try to prove the rate to be
optimal by using muscles
we failed
then we tried to prove it by the cops
method we failed again
and eventually we came up with a new
lower bound it's a combination of what
she was lama and in the comments matter
and
to prove
and their procedure
is optimal and for us rightfully small
and uh
s is smaller than squared or
smaller than square square root of n
so the calms method you know is is a
very good way to get a lower bound for a
sparse vector estimation that could be
for every role
and ashima's lemma is a very good way to
combine all rows together
then to get a matrix low bound that's
how we succeeded
and we have some other follow-ups as
well
and the first one is very natural one is
the universe covering submission
situation
it has a thousand graphic model
interpretation
and since we have a gaussian working
model interpretation then we care about
and for each edge
you know coming to inference that means
you know and we were considering a
synthetic efficient estimation of each s
under a somewhat necessary and
sufficient condition
and we also considered a matrix
functional estimation a combination of
variables
and uh
posterior contraction uh bone stanford
misfiring of course all you know
following uh uh
the pioneering paper of uh
peter and uh analisa
so that's uh the first part
of uh
of my of my talk
and the second part is on network
analysis
uh in in 2006 uh about 17 uh 16 years
ago and changing organized a conference
at princeton
and to celebrate on peter's 65th
but actually birthday i guess peter was
actually 66 uh i could be wrong
and so
and peter uh uh uh
there was a uh prereception uh before
the conference started
and peter was there
uh
sitting at a corner
and some of
uh neil faculty was sitting or standing
around him uh just to hear whatever he
would say
i remember and peter was talking about
network analysis
and and also and suggested it it's
important to have more statistics to be
involved in network analysis
and to be honest i did not really know
what appeal was really talking about
until and six years later
and uh peter was given a talk at yale
and in a workshop and tony and i
organized
and peter was talking about network
models
and history with this
important paper
a ground breaking paper
and to unify to provide a unifying view
and to get
several communities together
including social sciences statistics
probability and physics
and through an unprepared estimation and
a graph
and by our audience over a result
a lot of people that also proved another
fascinating result they showed that and
a new mentor with a modularity a newman
government virtuality and it could be a
good way to do community detection
and when sigma is strong and everyone
has at least more than friends
and then you could identify the
community
everyone's community information
with high probability
and the chance
to be wrong
is explicitly small
in the end of land paper and we will
point out and several important
directions and to work on
this uh the first one is
when the signal is not strong
and we may have lessened morgan friends
and people expected mle and vision
approach and should be optimal
and this is a lot of direction
uh
to think about more about uh guava and
the non-permission it's amazing
and we when we have infinite
community
and then that means we need to do some
kind of bias and virus trade-off
and the last one over here is spectral
clustering
and it's possible mle animation approach
may not be completely detractable
and spiritual classroom could be a very
good alternative
so i will check on peter's ideas
and buy a very simple model on the
stochastic particle model with two
communities
we observe an adjacency matrix
so there are nodes and there are some
edges
and aj is equal to one
then they said nash
peter i assume this is how the model is
generated
and we evolve in two communities
and the community assignment id benue
pie
if i and j are in the same community
then the aiga is generated from
bernoulli pij
and the pij could be
will be equal to a
if lie in a different community then pij
is equal to b
and they are independent of annuity
so it's a very simple model
and you can make the model slightly more
complicated uh
more complicated and to have yourself
two parameters you may have three
parameters or you may have instead of
two communities you might have k
components and but the story will not
change
so then peter consider a private
estimation i believe and peter called by
pi a and b are global practices
and called a community detection and a
local practice
and also an important part is graphing
estimation
and in this talk i do not distinguish
graphene estimation
with
estimation of the mean of the adjacency
matrix
i am sorry for that and i do that just
to make my life easier
so in this beautiful paper
and they study a global primary
estimation
by math of moments
it was dedicated to eric lemon and
peter's advisor
of course and iu and lisa's grand
advisors
they consider very general models
including circuit board model with gay
communities
and i'll restrict
their consideration to our toy model and
that means k is equal to two
and there are three primes to ask me
so what this is their proposal they said
okay we use method moments
we have three parameters pi let's say
the proportion of the
community one
we have a that's a connection
probability intermediate one and uh p
and uh uh connection probability between
coming one and community two
so we need three equations
then the first equation they use they
called the number of ads in the network
then the second equation then they count
number of two connected ads
in the network
and then the third equation they count
a number of three kinetic eyes
with some constraints
so then we have three equations and
solve these three equations then they
get rooted in consistency
so that means they could estimate a b
and pi with one of n rate and under the
square error loss
and then there is under an assumption
over here and okay uh this assumption is
just an assumption to make sure that
jacobi
and for those equations
will not be degenerate
oh by the way uh i i i'm assuming b is
an order of one if it's not a lot of one
there will be just a scanning factor a
square over here as long as a is not too
small everything will be fine
so that's uh that's uh
the method for moments paper
and we and we've uh revisited the paper
uh by considering a graph of estimation
uh again you know the graphite
estimation is just estimating is the
other estimation of the mean of the
jesus matrix
so okay the dominating uh we use a least
square approach
uh and then to get the upper bound that
means we need to get the complexity
and the dominating uh uh
uh a factor uh uh in the
uh complexity is
the number of potential uh uh community
assignments and which is an order of
total n
and if you take a
log of that quantity then we get in
that's why we get such a number about
one of them
and if we uh look at this matrix
and count and how many a a hat minus a
in that
that would be an order of n squared so
that result immediately implies we could
estimate
uh
after another on one of n is reproducing
and this work uh this result but without
this assumption
so uh and by the way and uh you can
easily extend uh this uh result to
uh uh uh
about it with communities
and also to a
graphing estimation
and so since you know uh we seem to be
slightly doing uh slightly better uh
than this result and without uh you know
a
in this sense without this assumption
so and then and we are revisiting the
problem again
and that means okay under that
assumption
can we do better that was peter's
question
it turns out
you could do better
and the weight over here is one of n
squared
so it is as good as
you know the naval information of
everyone
so that sounds uh too good to be true
the reason is it is right you know you
look at the power okay how about your
accurate pi you're actually apart from
the you know basically by normal
observation you cannot look at it and
weight like one of n squared as in pi
that means it's hard for you to get a
better rate you know one of the
instagram
and we are avoiding that
by another extreme pi
we try to estimate
the exact
proportion
of community one in the network
that's the realization
of
of uh of uh of the uh of community
uh so so so uh uh uh
uh yeah that was a fun work uh but it
was not published
uh uh and i mean we did not publish and
uh because
we couldn't get the counseling right
uh at one time
i believe i i thought i you know we had
a proof
and uh to get the customer right
and then peter was looking at the proof
they say hey harry how do you go from
this step to that step so the proof was
wrong
that was amazing
uh another direction i'm putting out uh
uh
in uh
peter's uh grand breaking paper uh is
community tension
so and he expected a maximum level
estimation
uh should be optimal and uh even when
the circular noise ratio uh when the
signal noise region is not very strong
that means people may have less than
logarithmic friends
uh so that uh and in this paper what we
did was just to reconfirm what people
exactly uh expected and years ago
and the exponent over here and it could
be fun for this year uh the exponent
over here is really divergence of order
one half and when he uh was born 100
years ago and this year there's a
conference in none of him
it's called we need 100.
so we have some auto follow-ups as well
and uh you know we obtained the autobahn
uh by using mle
and but mle is not completely acceptable
and so
we found another idea of being able to
use special classroom to get in a warm
initiation
and then we do a one-step uh local
refinement uh to obtain optimality uh to
obtain the operating rate
so and one step refinement idea is not
new to peter and peter proposed that of
47 years ago uh his celebrating paper of
uh uh
uh uh
uh in uh one in uh
uh in jason i believe it's called a
white staff
hoover estimate
so that uh
that was the second topic hey how many
minutes do i have
uh you have about
let's say i think
10 let's say
so uh this is the third topic
and
it's on a variation influence
and uh in 2016
and uh lisa organized a conference at
michigan
and appealer
was the primary speaker
and he was talking about a basic
influence on the for a community
detection
and for uh information influence and the
most important thing is to calculate
posterior
or for both patients or frequencies
and uh so
and for the posterior you know it may
not be completely intractable so peter
proposed to use mean field approach
what does that mean that means the
procedure could be a super kind super
complicated and a distribution and then
they uh they approximate that
distribution by product imagine
and peter started with this paper in the
talk
with david troy
and they show that and version based of
books
at least under a strong
second noise racial condition when the
signal is very strong
they show that and to make a difference
using the original
or like hood without knowing
uh anything about the uh
community information
and and uh to uh to do inference for
global practice
and uh and you can do as well as you
know the labels
so actually what the proof was modern
variation the universe works
so i
and i was highly skeptical and uh and i
i was in the talk and uh and uh i
remember and when i was in the talk i
sent an email to my co-authors and i
said okay and this is kind of crazy idea
and uh can you guys hear
and uh original influence would fail
because the posterior you know nitrogen
could be super complicated and how could
you know a product of magic would be a
good approximation
so this is exactly what i asked like
authors to do and again let's think
about the toy model okay this is like
hood my pid is either equal to a equal
to b let's assume that unknown
so we have a prior and uh for the label
information and then we calculate
posterior and on which is not
computationally determinable and because
uh uh because and we have uh
two to the power n realization for z
there
so okay we approximate
uh the posterior which is
uh uh you know this is the joint
distribution of n uh bernoulli but they
could be highly dependent
and then approximated
by a product imagine let's midfield
approach
and this is another way to write it down
and it turns out
for this simple model and
this objective function has an explicit
form
so what i asked my caller to do was it
is and to show that
and
this outcome
is bad
and when the signal noise ratio is not
strong
so your signal is strong of course
better proof that is works all right
actually he proved more than that
and since you know this objective
function is not complex in pi so what we
did was to use a batch coordinate
ascending variation entrance in any
region values
and uh to approximate
the maximum
and i actually suggest
yeah magazine
and to our surprise
and when we share with these
if the initializer
is strictly better
let me run and guess if you guessed
anyone's committee
information but flipping coin they will
get an error one half
so if it's strictly better than running
guess
and then after a number of login steps
and
uh nutrition works is very optimal as
long as you could get a consistent
estimation of the communities
so i tried to
find a good sphere but i failed
and we have some autofocus as well and
for example a global convergence of em
with my colleague and uh uh
with randomly decision and uh was
considered uh two component gaussian
mixtures
and but the idea over there cannot be
extended to general gaussian mixture and
now we are overcoming that by over
precision and optical transfer theory
and i and
at this moment my uh uh
research focus uh is is to understand
and statistical and computational
guarantee of some non-convex
organization problems
so okay a brief summary
uh in the past 10 or 15 years
uh peter has been my lighthouse
and will continue to be of course
a thank you leader and happy birthday
thank you harry for the wonderful
presentation indeed peter's uh i mean
academic uh i mean powerhouse has guided
many of us here so let me see if there
are many people working
in similar areas i didn't see anybody
online let me see if there are any
questions so while people are thinking
so uh so let me ask you a very simple
question
uh so you have done wonderful work right
so uh and in many real world i don't
like network or coherence matrix
for financial investment or for
understanding the relationship
so there are always dynamic aspects do
you
thinking how to do
[Music]
dynamic modeling on how
correct sport coins matrix evolve or how
network evolve
yeah i'm sorry i did not do that and i
know uh uh you know some of uh
peter's students
have done wonderful work and along that
line
and for both uh uh you know for the
network and the graphic models yeah uh
sorry i did not do any work along that
line and it's of course it's fascinating
and by the way you know and of course
yeah and uh uh you're you also did a lot
of work uh uh you know uh around the
same time with the leader and uh on uh
on logical various matrices and uh
low-rank structures uh
thank you harry uh
and the
questions from the audience
okay so uh so harry since everybody
choir let me ask you a second question
right
so uh i mean you got very nice uh mini
max rates which certainly depending on
the
uh the long you use and the space you
use right so if i want to do let's say
some kind of hypothesis testing uh
and i would like to understand the
uh the uncertainty quantification of uh
let's say transmission estimation sparse
coin spatial estimation under certain
norms
do you have any thoughts or literature
on that
um
oh yeah you probably still hear me well
i i don't know i i
what i did along that line was very
minor
and uh uh
i did you know some uh matrix
functionals uh
uh to get a phone stand from these type
of results and uh also you know just
some kind of symmetricality for graphic
model stuff and but there could be a lot
more to do right you know and uh
uh uh
yeah along the line i of course in a lot
of results i have done
and uh quite limited i i know uh
vladimir kozinski has done a lot of uh
interesting work along the line as well
uh
uh thank you
yeah now there are two questions so
yeah another question so assume that you
talked about this network analysis
assume i didn't give you a sample of the
network
but let's say
i observed an epidemic on the network it
has two communities have you thought
about how to estimate the network if i
just give you how the epidemic threats
assume you know all the parameters of
the academics if you want to say oh
these are the two communities
oh i'm sorry i cannot really hear uh
uh
do you know the question
okay can you hear me now
oh yeah
okay hi harry is this christian i have a
question if you had assume sometimes we
don't really see the network but let's
say we see an epidemic spreading on a
network and assume you know it has two
communities
and i ask you to
find the communities or estimate how
strong the connection between the
community is if you see the epidemic
spread and let's say you know all the
parameters of the epidemic
so in general this idea that maybe i
can't really observe the network but i
can see something happening on the
network you see this
uh summary problem right
and uh something could be very advised
oh
i'm i'm sorry i did nothing along that
direction uh yeah that's yeah that's
that's another very interesting dragging
the thing about uh
all right um let me ask a question this
is lisa harry
very nice talk
um so you know when we were doing all
that um log p over and stuff
we called it the large piece mullen you
know you and us and everyone
maybe 15 years ago
um but now going to the theme of the
conference i think
large piece milan is not so much the
case now it's large b largen and
everything's very large
how much
of those rates and those results do you
think translates to this new big data
context where everything's very big
uh
i guess uh you know
yes we may have big uh large and large p
these days
and
uh but we know that you know the model
we have been thinking about tend to be
uh
very simplified
and um the data could be very uh you
know
heterogeneous
and uh and and we may have a lot big end
but it's not necessarily we have begun
there
uh uh you know uh because the data is
not from genius
so so uh so i think uh uh large large
piece more and
is still important
so harry
in interest of time thank you very much
for wonderful i mean talk that touch
many as well
yeah
okay so the uh the next speaker uh is uh
jess uh skelhon uh eugene mayer
professor of statistics and political
science